yeah hello welcome to this video it's a
little bit little bit later this start
but Sir I touch it to something with my
camera to avoid the stuttering it didn't
work ok let's do let's play against sep
lee yeah suddenly is pretty no way to 10
but place an absolutely nine yeah here
black moves the Queen around a lot but
um that's how it is so it's a somewhat
risky line here but if you want to be
safe you have to play the Queens gambit
let's go all the time so kind of wonder
should have probably started with g6
mmm 94 looks problematic I really have
no development him
yeah 94 looks like the most obvious move
but it does not have to play that ok at
least I get castles
I would like to definitely like to get
rid of my my bishop es el gym that is
probably equal right but it's not the
kind of situation where i can do much
Bishop takes home I know it was played
quickly seems to be fairly confident
that this is right boom maybe it is but
I'm not sure so what's on here some c4
maybe see 490 eggs just too much can
prepare see for you
[Music]
maybe it just plays be three-year trying
to block everything
v3 looks kind of okay I mean I'm
threatening c4 yeah I think that is a
threat
no taking a volume p 3 looks extremely
normal not quite sure what is hesitation
is all about I'm not sure what I think I
curly play is six see some connection
this year no camera is still stuttery it
did not happen in the live stream
recently a bit weird yeah he's taking
ages here maybe it's still some kind of
disconnect ok so here yeah I still go e6
especially now at the bishop he I mean I
cannot take on his 60 ok so what's going
on here
fatigue d5 now that's probably f6 which
that could be extremely critical
[Music]
not sure not sure about it I mean that's
wrong I'm sure that it is critical but
i'm not sure if it then it is bad
tha droop jade is pretty quick he's
playing this great I mean and I don't
understand this this guy is really two
thousand he has a one hundred percent
score against me and finds all the great
Mooseheads always amazing yeah this is
strong
yep it's just wrong maybe I can still
fight here with the bishop cut off
I mean hundred percent convinced he has
two out of two but for someone ready to
a thousand this is pretty strong okay so
any chances here this one
yeah I don't know it doesn't really do
all that much but ok take the pawn
[Music]
say any way to time or date to post some
problems it's got a 94 them against us
nitey voice extremely salt it down not
good
Queen age three I mean he can come with
that but
so be not easy eight seconds check my
completely lost the thread them white
forfeits on time yeah bit of a strange
game always skeptical about those they
have a very low rated account and like
one hundred percent against me that's
always a bit strange yeah anyway so
let's see and then this long break there
are some irritating moments in this game
always kind of yeah difficult nowadays
but I think I'm judging what happened at
the end he probably just played a very
good game and then lost the thread so
here it took him like ages to play this
bishops insects I will just go be three
here probably you're blocking this and
then continue from there and then f5
yeah yeah I was just taking stuff yeah
maybe the check first but this this
seems to be critical I actually have the
check check I actually have this check
why didn't I check him what oh my god
there was a terrible game and I'm just
totally lost but would he couldn't
somehow yes speed up it's it's a total
win but it's like here things are not
that easy anymore yeah this is jaclyn
yeah he basically played very well i
mean but i can't play Bishop e3 check
which for some reason i told her
totally ignored check I don't know what
this is probably go that's hard to say
as a human player my king position is
still shaky so I'm kind of skeptical
here it could be one of those cases
where the engine just needs a bit of
time until it sees the danger it looks
it looks critical to me as well but of
course it's totally sick to just drop
the bishop and just say okay I'm a piece
down I said simply the only thing that
as so I says somewhat didn't see the
check I mean I saw that this is my check
so yeah it's just a bad game yeah okay
let's hope for something better next
time I didn't switch on the engine I was
a that was bad yeah them here the
situation when I sat down here like this
chance is not clear to me the engine
gives a white a slight advantage but
what does a slight advantage since this
mean it this can never be a slight
advantage I think it should be something
yeah the question is of black holes or
not and okay maybe you can hold and
escape to some slightly was ending or so
Adam in general this looks very
threatening to me ok guys thanks for
watching